hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute heute leute beute
ich habe heute für euch was sehr sehr
nice am start höchstwahrscheinlich hp
schon im titel gelesen aber ich habe das
kleinste handy der welt bestellt und ich
zeige euch erstmal nur die rückseite so
in dieser box ist angekommen es ist
wirklich unfassbar klein also lächerlich
klein schon fast wird die bereits
richterin dann erzähle ich erst mal
ruhig gekauft habe ich habe das bei
einem chinesischen online store wie
sollte es anders sein gekauft und ratet
mal was ich dafür bezahlt habe 120 euro
weil ich noch versucht ja wird sich auch
mit leute ich hab für dieses handy dass
ich gleich zeigen werde 12 euro bezahlt
inklusive versand aus china ich bin echt
gespannt ob es funktioniert und hier ist
das ding was ist das mein daumen ist
viereinhalb mal so groß wie dieses handy
und gucken wir uns mal die box an
sieht auf den ersten blick nicht
schlecht aus muss man sagen der und 70
wales der mini von where is called the
voice call das ding jetzt wo du kaufst
dir ein iphone hast du einen wolfgang
ottens leute anrufen mit deiner stelle
aber das original ja voll kriegt man nur
hier mit acht das ist der kreis coesfeld
wird
ach so das könnte das vorbild fürs
iphone the best and des mordes backup
vorne in die word 0,66 zoll bildschirm
sehr gut mein fernseher brauchen
ungefähr soviel micro-sim-karte bla bla
bla bla wohl diesmal hier raus ein sehr
überschaubarer lieferumfang wir haben
hier ein kabel und eine anleitung jetzt
ein bisschen raus was ist das denn
das handy hat einen seiner rückseite
einfach so ein airport
die krieger was trägst du da gerade und
ich eine webseite der stadt sieht wird
wissen nicht was ist louis wir waren
manchmal als erfolg fragen das ist doch
dass das neue headset von von gut für
das weingut hat einfach natürlich drehen
doch mal haben wir
so alter junge leute denken da war
einfach so dass nicht mal dreckig savoir
das ist dass ich das handy ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich habe das schon mal an den
lader gesteckt und deshalb sollte es
jetzt problemlos anzuschneiden seien
aber erst mal bitte close up und porn
wie ich diese folie abziehen
oh nein
neben alten schnell gemacht sie vorher
von dem 0,66 zoll bildschirme bezogen ja
ich hab's ja oben die marke l lacht da
es ist eine volltastatur sogar mit
buchstaben darauf welcher mensch
schreibt mit diesem handy sms guckt euch
das mal bitte an ich will lieber in
meine handfläche darf hier leute ist ein
funktionsfähiges handy war das areal
topf buchstaben braucht der sind post
haben braucht er stellt auch diese
kleinen dinge booster dahinter kam
erkennt so krass herangezoomt man
erkennt dass wirklich kaum ich probiere
ich bitte da mit der sms zu schreiben
bleibt auf jeden fall dran und jetzt
würde ich sagen schreiben wir das handy
erst mal an jetzt durch mal einfach die
rote taste intuitiv ich würde sagen dass
die richtige zeigt mir an ok das hier
ist das display ist sie ganz so scheiße
aus oder ich man muss sich vor augen
halten das ist ein 12 euro handy dirk
vogel man kann sogar kontakte da drin
haben message als wenn also tatsächlich
sms punkt führen karosserie vergangene
anrufe ist sieht echt gut aus so weit
zwölf roman sondern nur 300 milliarden
stunden batterien ungefähr so viel wie
ein iphone ungefähr gefühl zu ferien
iphone aber ein iphone hat 2007 15 6,8
mal soviel oder sobald das hätte jemand
neben seinen zeigefinger aber ich sollte
meinen zeigefinger halten ja die
multimedia ich krieg da rein und uplay
audioplayer denken wir hören auf musik
mankell ist ein headset erster direkter
hitze dabei waren laut connect wie
wollte man der audioplayer ist nicht
verfügbar
juni connect hat connected noch ok
schade was es noch gibt außer multimedia
nach multimedia folgt noch bluetooth
teiler
organizer klar kalender und sowas auch
seid einfach so ein gerät ist da ich
einen kalender magic woman oder wo es
nötig war das irgendwie so ein stimm
verzerrer oder sowas
ich glaube man kann nicht einfach auf
deutschland stellen gehen wir weiter
settings profiles time and settings
language english englisch oder deutsch
französisch polnisch portugiesisch
italienisch deutsch und kann das
kleinste jedoch bald stellen ist ich
hoffe dass auch deutschland
du kannst das tech benutzen und dann
würde ich mal sagen tue ich jetzt die
sim karte einfach mal in mein neues
handy rein sim karte steckt leute ich
kann es nicht glauben er wenn das jetzt
funktioniert dann weil sie echt nicht
mehr gewähren netz wird gesucht telekom
es funktioniert einfach wirklich
studiert wirklich wer solche anrufe nur
die frage ist wie viel von mir jetzt
technisch so muss die nummer eins in
europa aber bei uns auf dem festplatz an
der haut ein bisschen länger als normal
aber es funktioniert es klingt ganz
normal
also ich würde noch mal an
ich guck mal einfach so nein das ist
übertrieben da auch zucker also ich rufe
jetzt einfach mal gerne an sagt seine
orden die strecke fahren zurzeit nicht
erreichbar
es ist einfach flächig muss man sagen
ich wobei man sagen einfach nur frohe
weihnachten
ich würde dir wünschst du dir irgendwas
abend so leicht
ich finde es sogar hellmann hilfe
monaten steckt dieses gerät zeitlich rum
kompletten keinen fall strommitte mit
seinem quad ins ohr
keiner geht ran ich anrufen wer die
nicht sagen jedenfalls was praktisch
also ich mein weniger platz ist
praktisch ein muss wie die fis das
gefällt nicht griffen
ich probiere wahlwiederholung war ja
hallo was geht man alles klar
ich wollte noch mal anrufen tier vor
weihnachten wünschen und schönes fest
bitte danke schön anruf abgebrochen
okay aber die sprache weit ich davor war
richtig gut
ich schreibe ja noch mal bei quads
application bleibt damit an ge habe
keine ahnung von her alter wie laut das
ist probier's mal so
hallo auch wenn du willst zeig ich habe
nur das kleinste handy der welt gerade
und deshalb beruflich ein bisschen rum
ach so ganz gemerkt auch der am schon
wieder abgebrochen
ok ich schreib irgendwie gut wir sind
hier im keller dass man also jahr zwei
mal sind jetzt die anrufe abgebrochen
allerdings sind ja in einem keller in
sohn und handy kann natürlich nicht so
eine antenne die in diesem handy ihr
sein dass sie das dicke auf der hand
also in der hand habe einfach so auf dem
kopf habe der schulter aufeinander okay
leute was kann man noch zu diesem handy
sagen ausschlusskriterium für mich habe
ich gerade festgestellt es hat einfach
eine kamera wie keine kamera frechheit
zwar die rückseite dass er bestimmt
platz für eine kamera oder eigentlich
schon
und neben dem stöpsel wäre das handy
einnimmt wird bestimmt von der kamera
gewesen ich habe gerade von der antwort
bekommen seine reaktion darauf dass hier
gerade ein buch war mit dem handy
geschrieben mit diesem wenn ihr euch
gerade angerufen und hersteller haba
haba
in diesem video kein plan ist mega cool
wenn man so was einfach nur zu einer
party mit nimmt und sagt stehr vor ihr
geht mit diesen dingen zu
man sagt ja gar nicht alle nummern gibt
mal ein
wir werden niemals in ihrem leben nummer
kriegen glaub ich na gut das war's dann
wobei sebastian doch mal kurz plätze
du hast jetzt das lebensverändernde
telefon steckt dass jemand bitte ins ohr
so wie man es halt macht das ist einfach
so dahin
was dann den code noch mal und wir
probieren jetzt einfach mal wir rufen
mich selbst an ok damals also das ist
der der ohrstöpsel das selber statt
selber den rausch sieht es so aus das
heißt hier ist ein lautsprecher
ja und auf der vorderseite auch und auf
der vorderseite ist auch ein
lautsprecher dass selbst bei
lautsprecher beiden seiten ja und ich
will nicht mehr gehört dass keine
meistens laut muss sich nicht auf
tatsachen macht ja für die richtige
erfahrung für zweck also es ist dann
wirklich ziemlich ziemlich klar dass
audio einfach so du kriegst das malz
feeling ich ruf dich jetzt mal an du
hier klingelt jetzt da muss ein kurzer
herausnehmen die malkunst hingegen hallo
es gibt es wieder einen klub so leute
wie mache jetzt mal entsprach
qualitätscheck ruf jetzt mal sebastian
auf dem kleinen handy an der konzern
hallo hallo
die sparte ist übertrieben gut die
gesprächsqualität monster.de kein
unterschied jetzt wirklich nicht reden
ein bisschen länger
und schon wieder abgebrochen aber es ist
wirklich wirklich eine gute qualität
also leute abschließend kann man zum
handy sagen es ist eigentlich echt nice
handy für das kleine geld so ich weiß
nicht warum man sich so etwas ernsthaft
holen sollte als spaß okay aber es ist
sogar auch funktional gesehen echt nicht
schlecht deshalb